do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video well here we are again my
friends it's Sunday night and another
episode of Game of Thrones has just
ended hopefully by now most of you have
noticed I like to upload a video every
time a new episode is over since
tonight's episode was the battle for
Winterfell I'm sure everyone is ready to
talk about all the crazy [ __ ] that just
happened I would definitely love to do
that as soon as I can by the time you're
watching this video I will be working on
my breakdown video for that episode
hopefully I can get that out as early as
Monday morning as I sit here right now
making this video you're watching I have
no idea what happens in that battle I
have my own theories of course but since
I'm recording this on Saturday I have no
idea who wins the battle or which
characters died during the battle as you
can see by the title of this video I
want to take a look ahead at the next
big battle which should be right before
the season finale episode 5 will be
directed by Miguel support snick the
same man that directed tonight's episode
this will be the battle for the Iron
Throne in King's Landing now before we
get started I do want to thank the
sponsor of today's video this video is
sponsored by Squarespace whether you
need a domain a website or even online
store I would highly recommend that all
of you go and check out Squarespace as I
said before I want to talk about the
final battle for the Iron Throne Cersei
Lannister still remains to have full
control over King's Landing as of right
now assuming John and Daenerys survive
the battle at Winterfell they will
eventually need to go down to take care
of Cersei Lannister
they obviously cannot leave her on the
Iron Throne in my opinion Cersei has no
intentions of leaving King's Landing
even if all of our soldiers are defeated
I still think Cersei would rather blow
up the city before she ever handed it
over to someone else like many of us I
suspected there may still be a lot of
wildfire under the city the Mad King had
this stuff underneath the entire city
there is also a very good chance that
Qyburn may have made Cersei her own
wildfire
my little birds investigated and
suggest ameno something magical so even
if they do back Cersei into a corner she
might kill everyone in King's Landing I
think all of the survivors from the
Battle of Winterfell will be able to
take over King's Landing but how will
they be able to get to Cersei before she
does something really crazy whenever
they are able to get inside King's
Landing Cersei might lock herself inside
of the red key where no one can reach
her so I started to think of some ways
we could see some of the characters get
inside of the red keep to kill Cersei
and or Qyburn before they do anything
stupid now I'm sure most of my
subscribers already know I think Tyrion
Lannister will eventually betray
Daenerys Targaryen I feel like they have
been foreshadowing this for quite some
time however let's say Tyrion does not
betray Dany even though I think he will
there is always a chance that maybe he
doesn't as we all know this character
has been on a bit of a downslide as of
lately he continues to do things to make
Daenerys question his allegiance so I
started wondering what can Tyrion do
that could actually help Daenerys and
maybe even get some of his respect back
even Sansa Stark said she thought Tyrion
was the cleverest man in Westeros but he
continues to do stupid things
well maybe Tyrion can come up with
something clever that can help them win
the battle for King's Landing if you
remember last season he did have a
strategy to get inside of Casterly Rock
since he knew the castle very well he
knew how to access the sewer system that
led back into the castle that is how the
unsullied were able to get inside became
Queen at the age of 19 when I reached
manhood in charge of all the drains and
cisterns in Casterly Rock a most
highborn plumber what would never flowed
better and all the [ __ ] found its way to
the sea interesting thing about my
father he built our house up from near
ruin he built our army he built Casterly
Rock as we know it but he didn't build
the sewers that was beneath him so he
gave the job to the lowest person he
could find
me now as we all know that did not work
out very well not only were most of the
Lannister soldiers on their way to
Highgarden but your own Greyjoy also
showed up and sunk Taney ships this
obviously made Tyrion look really stupid
that made Dany think that maybe he
doesn't want to defeat his family after
all now although this did not work at
Casterly Rock
maybe this could work at King's Landing
this is also another Castle that Tyrion
knows very well in fact him and Varys
snuck out of the castle right after
Tyrion killed his father this section of
the castle is also located inside of the
red key so we know he definitely knows
how to get in and out without anyone
noticing him now I highly doubt that he
would go and do this himself but maybe
he could send someone like let's say
Arya Stark how to gain access inside of
the red keep in the middle of the night
we know that Arya Stark is one of those
characters that could get around
undetected she learned how to do this
during her training at the house of
black and white even during this season
we heard Jon Snow say how did you sneak
up on me so we know that Arya is very
light on her feet
Arya can even wire someone else's face
once she gets inside that would mean
even if someone did see her they would
not know that it was Arya Stark she does
have the ability to disguise herself as
a man so she could potentially disguise
herself as a Lannister guard or even
someone from the city watch that would
give Arya complete access to the red key
without anyone getting suspicious also
way back in the second season there were
several references of the hidden tunnels
under King's Landing
these scenes just so happened to include
Tyrion Lannister because he was the one
that got the maps of the city Stannis
knows King's Landing he knows where the
walls are strongest and he knows which
gates are weakest everything he said in
that scene about Stannis is also true
about himself he knows King's Landing he
knows its weaknesses he was the one that
was trying to figure out how to defend
King's Landing
therefore he may know how to get around
any and all defenses that may be made by
Cersei now the most interesting scene is
from the very next episode right before
the Battle of Blackwater Bay started
this is one Varys brings Tyrion the maps
of all the secret tunnels under King's
Landing
the map you asked for must be 20 miles
of tunnels beneath the city closer to 50
the Hungarians built this city to
withstand a siege so as you can see he
knows the secrets of King's Landing
like I said earlier we know there will
be another battle for the Iron Throne
not only will their soldiers attack the
city but we will most likely see a
dragon attack the city however that
doesn't mean Cersei welcome outside I
don't think she will leave the city no
matter how bad things get and she may
even try to blow up King's Landing
herself so they may have to get someone
inside to kill Cersei and or Qyburn as
soon as they can now there is still one
other way they can do this even if
Tyrion Lannister and Varys would betray
Dany or they die some other way they
might still be able to gain access
inside of the red cape without anyone
knowing they're there we saw someone
else sneaking around the red keep all
the way back in the first season this
was when we saw Arya Stark chasing
around the cat down in the dungeons of
the red key this was also when Arya
overheard Varys and Illyrio talking
about the NARAS Targaryen she eventually
finds her way back outside by following
the drain system that drain emptied
right out onto the water Arya Stark
might be able to do that again only
instead of finding her way outside she
can backtrack and go into the dungeons
of the red key since that drain emptied
right out onto the water all they would
need to do is wait until the middle of
the night then have Arya take a little
boat right up to that drain we already
saw Theon Greyjoy do something very
similar in the first episode if he was
able to sneak onto the silence than Arya
or whoever else should be able to get
into that drain without anyone noticing
as soon as she gets inside she can kill
one of the guards and wear their face
my becomes a girl I was always about and
I was always aware but the girl keeps
secrets
it doesn't that for a mantis boy them
you're one of them now then she could
either go kill Cersei or she can let
some of the other characters inside I
think this would be a clever way of
getting to Cersei without her even
knowing it was happening we could see
Tyrion Lannister tell everyone how to do
this to get back some of his respects or
we could see Arya Stark be able to use
her faceless men skills one more time
before the series is over either way I
think it could work also let us not
forget Arya Stark still has Gregor
Clegane and Cersei Lannister on her list
some fans say she will kill Cersei
Lannister this season and some even say
she will do this while she wears Jaime
Lannister's face no I don't know about
all that but I do think it would give
her away inside that Cersei may not
expect let me know what you think about
this idea do you think it could work or
will they just knock the damn castle
down leave your thoughts down below in
the comment section before I go I do
want to thank the sponsor of today's
video one more time this video is
sponsored by Squarespace
you can use Squarespace right now to
help build your own website now some of
you may think creating your own website
is not very easy to do but that's one of
the many great things about Squarespace
they make their service very easy to use
and understand even for someone like me
Squarespace has an all-in-one platform
that even provides 24/7 customer support
if you are thinking about building your
own website I would highly recommend
that you go to Squarespace comm for your
first free trial as soon as you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace comm slash
talking Thrones to save 10% off your
first purchase go to the description of
the video to find their link I would
really appreciate that anyways I want to
thank everyone for stopping by to watch
the video and I also want to thank
everyone who supports the channel on
patreon I hope to see you all come back
from my next breakdown video I'll see
you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]